des dizaines de mouettes retrouvées
mortes dans le bassin de la Sourderie
Montigny-le-Bretonneux selon les
résultats d'analyses la grippe aviaire
H5 N1 est responsable de cette incidence
survenue fin janvier c'est qu'à isolé
n’inquiète pas la direction
départementale de la protection des
populations qui assure la surveillance
de toute la chaîne alimentaire du chant
à l'assiette aucun foyer de
contamination n'a été détecté chez les
producteurs de volailles Yvelines le
fait que on sache que le virus circule
chez les oiseaux sauvages en
Île-de-France et dans les Yvelines a
incité à encore plus leur demander de de
plus encore plus vigilant que
habituellement c'était le beurre sur la
commune de Lognes produit 3000 volailles
sur son exploitation de 35 hectares il
cultive l'alimentation de ses animaux et
réalise la battage lui-même ses oiseaux
sont confinés dans les bâtiments depuis
fin novembre 2022 le nouvel arrêté
préfectoral ce qui impose c'est moi qui
suis éleveur de canard c'est de faire
des prélèvements toutes les semaines sur
les canards parce que le canard il est
porteur sain et on voit pas forcément
quand les canards sont malades
le poulet on voit qu'ils sont malades
parce qu'il meurent donc c'est rapide en
tant qu'elles veulent moi j'évite les
jardineries j'évite d'aller chez les
collègues j'évite de laisser rentrer les
gens chez moi donc même les vétérinaires
et tout j'aime bien voilà j'ai moins ils
viennent et mieux je me porte
l'agriculteur a décidé d'arrêter sa
production de palmipède pour se
consacrer un élevage moins contraignant
là je vais développer des poules des
races anciennes donc du coup j'ai
commandé des poussins de race anciennes
et donc là au printemps comme on vend
beaucoup de poules à mettre dans les
jardins et bah du coup je vais remplacer
les canards par une production de race
ancienne voilà que je vais vendre pareil
à la ferme aux détails des
expérimentations sont en cours pour la
commercialisation d'un vaccin sur les
volailles qui pourrait voir le jour à
l'automne 2023 l'Organisation Mondiale
de la Santé affirme que ce stade la
transmission à l'homme du virus est rare
et peu soutenu l'épidémie reste
cependant sous surveillance dans
l'éventualité d'une mutation plus
agressive